A couple of takes on components one from Richard Taylor,
a software component is an architectural entity.
It's concerned with a unit of the system's functionality or its data.
Once again, key here is the interfaces that it provides to the rest of
the world, and, according to Taylor,
the dependencies on its required execution context.
What that, what that means is, what does it take in order to
enable the component to run in a manner that it should?
Szyperski offers the following, that a component is a unit of composition.
We're going to take components,
we're going to put them together with contractually specified interfaces.
This means that the interfaces are explicit, the other components know about it,
they agree to it, and that these interfaces when you're
putting things together in configurations can be checked and enforced.